let's say you report something there's
almost a supposition on the on the part
of the person who's hearing that report
that oh well he wants to believe that
does that enter into it where there is
this confirmation bias or is it like
hell no I was like this could kill this
could blow up my plane or this could be
an enemy of the United States and I'm a
patriot I signed up to defend my country
at what level do you react negatively
someone said oh of course he just wants
to believe in this things in science
fiction like we all do but he's using
you know the fact that he's seen things
or witnessed things you know to bolster
that how do you guard against that
because that's a common claim that
people make right no I mean no frankly I
haven't heard people claim that um but
uh if they are um Sophia but um you know
for me I try to keep myself on the line
of what I've observed and what I've
directly talked to my colleagues and
what they've seen then today I'm just
doing my best to report on that and to
improve the the Aerospace safety around
it right and so that's where my all my
effort is so if you want to look at my
track record to justify my behavior then
they're gonna see nothing but me
focusing Aviation safety on this topic
because for me that's the most pragmatic
way that I can reach back and you know
be able to help the people that I used
to fly with whenever I engage in this
topic I do so two ways one I try to
engage with stakeholders within
government within DOD be able to provide
the answers to the most pricing
questions they have right because again
I'm trying to support National Security
here in aviation safety and that's the
best way to do it I directly interfaced
with solving the problems that they have
but we're also engaging in the
conversation uh on the Civil side as
well one of the activities that we're
planning at the aiaa is actually a small
sensor package that can be distributed
to schools and the general public and
we're looking to tie that in with a data
provider and service provider that would
look to donate that compute time to be
able to run algorithms that we're
generating at the AI double A to provide
that wider plethora of data it's about
trying to find patterns in that data so
the more that we have the more we can
kind of assess out some of those details
and that's a similar I think process
that can be done with eyewitness reports
and non-censor reports I think the the
bar is hiring even more data so that we
could pull out those Trends but I think
there is valid information to be pulled
out of there and mass right on average
as we look at the data
I was talking recently with a with a
colleague but he was in the military
intelligence field then he was talking
about you know the the preponderance of
events of anomalies that seemed to occur
near Military traffic Area 51 is a huge
you know Groom Lake Edwards Air Force
Base I was talking recently with a with
a colleague but he was in the military
intelligence field he was talking about
you know the the preponderance of events
of anomalies that seemed to occur near
Military traffic Area 51 is a huge you
know Groom Lake Edwards Air Force Base
is there anything you know to be said
about that like from the perspective of
Aviation safety at least like just avoid
those areas or could it be as some
suggest you know people are either
there's technology from an adversary
would like to go to those areas too and
get a sneak peek at an F-18 right um or
35. so what do you make of that is there
anything you know to this theory that of
course things are going to happen in
strange ways you know to call me when it
happens over Times Square kind of
reaction that I often get well my first
go-to here is Matthew's probably
observation bias involved so we're
seeing them there because we have uh the
sensors to actually be able to see now
with that I also don't think
you know this issue is going to be one
particular thing and I've been saying
for a while and you know we're going to
find adversarial platforms we're going
to find drones and things of that age
we're going to find trash that's great
and that's helpful to our national
security and we have systems in place to
mitigate that but there's a category
that you know we're ignoring essentially
that that data set and that's that's
what I find we need to work now and so
you know I think we're going to have
adversarial platforms around those bases
so there's going to probably be uptick
in you know unexplained or or
um
unidentified objects around those bases
maybe just because they're adversarial
platforms but I think there's an
observation bias as well and to your
point earlier you know you're talking
about kind of the Beijing probability of
of you know a commercial pilot versus
military pilot seeing these and what
that can affect it's such a small bubble
that commercial pilot can see so you
know when you talk about sightings from
fighter jets you know you have the
potential to get highly correlated data
across multiple sensors you know
different types as well as you know
different geographical locations of the
data perception if you will or the
sourcing ground-based sensors or
eyewitness statements things of that
nature you don't have that luxury
necessarily and so we would expect to
have much better data around those
systems what kind of supplementary
information data Etc quality quantity
calibration would you be most beneficial
to you in your mission so I uh I'm not
going to answer it the way you want but
we can go into some of that more stuff
after but to start I would say sadly uh
it's not a technological problem it's a
stigma problem uh and so if I was you
know in that position I would be pushing
in the middle management ranks in order
to standardize reporting on this across
all the services I think there's buying
at the top there's buy-in from operators
but there's you know essentially
middle rank officers that are you know
at that operational level that are
either going to make or break that
system and if they don't have buying one
there's also ways that you can Implement
that into training into the actual
Aviation uh training pipeline things of
that nature
um so stigma reduction of that will
increase pilot reporting uh to enable
new data uh that will allow this
conversation to be a normal scientific
Endeavor you know in our capitalistic
Market we can have you know an industry
around this we can advance the sensors
we can potentially get government
funding for uh these different companies
to be able to expand and provide
solutions to the government so reducing
stigma I think just allows this whole
conversation to open up
thank you